Okay i wanted to do a quick video updating
the current situation with the economyand
especially the situation with tax andpayments
for social care because these things have
changed recently there's been a lot of coverage on
it but i want to put a bit of economic perspective
okay so uh in October we did a video talking
about why Rishi Sunak is raising your taxes
if you haven't seen that go check it out
but basically Rishi Sunak raised 2.5%
on national insurance which means an
extra 2.5% tax taken off of everbody's
wages but not coincidentallybillionaires
like Rishi Sunak's father-in-law'sincome
they raised 2.5% tax on ordinary workers but
it does not apply to income earned by billionaires
now the reason they raised those taxes is
because they needed money to pay for elderly care
at the moment there's a situation where people
have to sell their homes to pay for their elderly
care people don't like this the government
wants to change it so what have they done how
they implemented this protection for elderly care
what they've done is they basically said everybody
has to pay the first £80,000 towards theirsocial
care and above that the government's gonna
cover the bill if you have a £1,000,000
in assets you have to use 8% of yourassets
if you are an ordinary family and
you've got assets of maybe £200,000
it might be less by the time you get very old
£150,000 you are going to end up having to pay
half of your assets away to pay for elderly care
so we have a situation here where the government
has raised taxes two and a half percent on
ordinary workers but not all on billionaires
and then they're using that
money to completely protect
almost all of the wealth of
millionaires and billionaires
but poorer families will be forced to lose almost
all of the assets including their home so we're in
a situation here where the government is raising
tax on ordinary workers but not on the super rich
to protect the assets of the rich and the super
rich and not the assets of ordinary workers
and to put this in context we're coming out of
covid an economic crisis in which ordinary people
are seeing rises in their bills their food costs
often financial hardship and we have seen the
biggest ever single year increase in billionaire
wealth 22% increase in billionaire wealth the
top 250 richest families in the country saw
their wealth increased by over £106 billion
which is more than 10 times what is needed
to pay for the annual cost of social care
so it's crazy what's happening um if you want to
understand why the rich have gotten so rich during
Covid check out my first video on this channel
"why the rich are getting rich from Covid-19"
but the most important thing is understand what's
happening here we have a chancellor whose father
in-law is a billionaire, a prime minister who is a
multi-millionaire or will become multi-millionaire
as soon as he leaves office, they're raising taxes
on workers, they're not taxing the super rich
and they're protecting the assets of the super
rich and they're not protecting assets of workers
this is going to mean that wealth flows
from ordinary people to the super rich
it's going to mean that ordinary families
cannot afford to get homes for theirkids
um ordinary families kids will struggle
to find a place to raise their families in
this is going to affect the economy check
out the video "what is wealth?" to see like
what wealth means and how inequality of wealth
affects the economy we're going to do another
video soon explaining really clearly exactly
how inequality of wealth damages the economy
but more importantly understand the situation
you're being taxed, the rich are not being taxed
the rich are having their assets protected you're
not having assets protected ordinary families
are struggling to get properties for their kids
ordinary workers are struggling to buy homes
and the super-rich have had their biggest
every single year increase in wealth so yeah
we're going to talk about how we can fight this in
upcoming videos but um yeah let your friends know
what is happening because um it's important here
wealth is being lost by ordinary families and it's
been accumulated by the rich which includes
a lot of members of our government that's all
so it's intentionally designed nationalinsurance
so that very rich peoplepay a very low percent
there is one otherthing they can do
with that mass amount of income
they can buy your mum's house